let's try the Sicilian mmm okay close
Sicilian
let's get that night out there they
should be okay well
ah all right we have going here what am
I already getting attacked is that
what's happening
can somebody tell me am I getting
attacked on chest cube it says it's the
Grand Prix attack should I be afraid
where does this Bishop like to be in the
Grand Prix attack c4 maybe I could rule
that out right away probably played a b5
let's see let's see about that I think
I'll just play Knight to e7 if the
knight gets pinned okay well I have no
worries about the bishop coming out so
now what do I do no I could already
anticipate that the bishop will be
playing the g2 this pond will likely
well visual probably played in g2 and so
the pond will likely play to g3 really
really is that how it would work okay so
okay this is likely the spot g2 for the
bishop how can I move forward with
things can always grab some space and I
could do that with the tempo with the
gain of time on the knight Knight here
pawn push kicks my night away maybe I
maybe I want to even though I could come
out in this direction maybe I want to
play g6 Bishop g7 maybe even get upon
into this f5 Square I'm gonna try that
it's definitely a little bit scary to do
that because f6 is incredibly weakened
now Bishop g7 Knight isse Evan or maybe
maybe I want to get in f5 I'm making a
lot an awful lot of pawn moves I only
have one piece out I'm three moves away
before I'm castled
um well what do you do what does what
does my opponent do g3 Bishop g2 and in
the meantime Bishop g7 f5 and then
declare my knight I don't think there's
a better square than g7 maybe this idea
of me getting an f5 is not a good one
maybe I should just play 97 I think this
is just more more direct I think I'm
getting a little bit too elaborate with
this idea of f5 I a little bit too a
little bit too much of a far-fetched
idea when the position can really open
up in a blink I think there should be a
greater weight placed on getting the
pieces out than making these silly pawn
moves and trying to establish a
particular structure which is really the
mindset that I was just in so how can I
follow up I think I could follow up with
rook b8 and do a b5 push I'm not afraid
of that well I don't know why that move
was even played actually maybe I should
be afraid if I don't know what's that my
first thought is what is it doing I'm
not sure what it's doing a 6 and b5 or
rook b8 and then pawn push I like rook
b8 because I see some tactical issues
that might be present on this diagonal
so if I can get in b5 with my rook
playing to b8 I'll do that pry it
instead of 86 to facilitate b5 and who
knows
actually maybe my a pawns real objective
is to maybe get in to get into a 5 maybe
b5 85b for ideas so now I think I need
to press forward I need to get this in I
think a4 is the right idea
white essentially is saying with a
or you know what if you're going to play
a b5 you're going to help my Brooke out
on a1 first that is a very purposeful
move if there's a downside to playing a
four it's that maybe I can now rely upon
the B 4 square for a little bit
for example if the Queen gets excited
about going elsewhere okay maybe c2
becomes a problem this this typical
grand-prix attack idea will often
include Queen e4 and then coming out in
this direction but we're not in that
position anymore the bishop is typically
on c4 and there isn't that pond on g3
and there can be that II 1 to h4 idea
with Bishop h6 Knight g5 stuff not the
case here I think I just keep going
follow through swing the bat completely
around ABA B if this pawn ever moves I
think one thing I could be doing right
away
well one square immediately that is
available is Knight f5 but maybe I could
just challenge it right away with f6 and
I don't know that it could be maintained
one drawback of playing f6 in response
to e5 would be e6 being weakened but I
do have my bishop still on its home
square that is maybe doing a good job
now maybe black is intending f5 and then
this bishop idea maybe now that I have
more development and I could look into
this this type of pawn advance now what
would it really accomplish maybe I
should do this first push this night
away actually I could push the night
away in a couple ways however if I do it
with B for the night can make use of a4
and then put pressure on c5 I don't want
to allow that so I think if anything
maybe I do there's paw in advance or
maybe I should do this first I really
don't know I'll try this one and then
this one
I don't know if it's a good idea but I'm
gonna I'm gonna give it a shot and now
if this pond moves I want to get the
light squares off my knight wants to be
able to take up a nice residence on this
square and I'll eventually need to
reroute this bishop in fact if I'm if
you're going to play f5 playing f5 right
here I have to be content with the
following I have to be content with
having the door slammed in my bishops
face right here on g7 because this
structure cannot be broken down any
further an e5 f4 structure can only be
broken down if my pawn is still on its
home Square challenging it with f6 but
I'm trying to make it work in the
following way I want to eliminate the
number one defensive piece for this
white King if this pawn moves then I'm
one step closer to doing just that
additionally I'm making this d5 square
available for my knight and then maybe
one day he could have thoughts of
jumping into III this Bishop is not
going to be going anywhere though it's
again it's going to be watching out for
that III square the meantime White's
clock is now drifting less than 40 I
have a minute advantage which is
atypical this seems purposeful I guess
this file is going to open up but we
could now have a structural change maybe
I could shift gears and say you know
what I'm going to take here and after
the recapture what we have is a three
versus two and I have these puns I think
far enough advanced - maybe cause white
sand problems follow that F takes II D
takes e maybe even this pawn advances
and as an option our way maybe just this
move right now
maybe I just don't know maybe I just
don't know what's best I really don't
know what's best maybe I should just
move if I move my bishop maybe I should
do this so that I don't have to worry
about any night moves that's this is
purposeful also my king can maybe play
here so I'm still not sure what's gonna
happen between these two pawns okay now
now we have that right I think I capture
away from the center so that that pond
does not become a liability I like to
get in bishop to that square okay I
don't know if that was correct I want to
hang out of my dark square bishop so
that's why I'm doing this Knight move
less than 10 for my opponent just like
this is a number one defender for white
he's a number one defender okay if I
could get rid of him things are looking
good it's hit this Queen oh she's gonna
give a check I could block though wasn't
I wasn't needed though clean up no time
time's up
okay good game let's back up flip and
see what is the big story here so close
Sicilian after after I play knight c6
right here we have e Co code b20 three
Sicilian closed and f4 is indicating the
Grand Prix attack but after six and
night there
should it be first the Bishop out I
really don't know I don't I don't know
these lines well enough to even make a
suggestion unfortunately we're only
three moves in but I don't know my
openings I've said it before so I have
to go with these general principles that
I would that's basically all I ever use
in blitz games over the board games
doesn't really matter
I don't know my openings doesn't seem
like this could be so bad but I do get
this pond advance in and you close that
Bishop up so I I don't know that I could
really say that this is a good idea if
anything I think you have to get that
Bishop out to be five if you can't go to
c4 I think it's I think you have to get
it to be five now right and then you're
you're getting ready to just smash up my
structure Bishop b5 I'm pretty sure is
the move here so go with that before you
hem your bishop in he becomes a prisoner
of your own pawns I don't really have
any issues I don't I really don't feel
like I have any issues here I have a
nice space I'm able to maintain this
structure maybe I kick the night away
maybe I capture if you capture then it's
just going to help me out I'm not really
worried on my end i'm not worried of eat
takes D because I respond with eat XD
and I have f5 available I have g4
available for my knight I can make
better use of D for jumping in f5 d for
etc so I think going elsewhere with the
bishop instead of taking an additional
move out to have to put in to open up
another door for the bishop just get
them out here and then go with the d3
and you can maybe still follow through
if I'm going to go with the King side
fiend keto you could follow through with
that idea
I was voicing during the game which is
to say Queen e1 to g4 or excuse me Queen
e1 to h4 ideas with the typical Grand
Prix attack f5 Bishop h6 stuff so we get
into this I don't know what was the
purpose of King each one I'm I can't
really put my finger on that one but oh
that that's not to say that there isn't
a reason I just I wasn't I wasn't seeing
it sometimes I have seen a reason to do
this King move so like if the bishop
plays here and let's say a knight came
here to attack it could back up to g1
but first and foremost the bishop could
never make use of e3 because of a fork
and of course there's not a knight that
can
make you some g4 but anyhow that's
something I've seen
if you encounter a similar setup a
reason to maybe do that King h1 mover
maybe just to get it off that diagonal
certainly I think I think it definitely
is a safer square than g1 but I think
there's maybe more purposeful moves to
be running forward with maybe what might
those purposeful moves be I'm not really
seeing it I guess it's kind of tough
this is kind of tough
I think this black is kind of better
here I don't know I'm not seeing it
I'm not seeing that a clear plan for
white 'if I've is always coming to mind
to shut down the bishop but you're
always again having to having to deal
with f6 in response and if you can't
maintain that pun well is it they're
really gonna be worth it I'm not so sure
I don't know really what to recommend
here for white but my earliest
recommendation is definitely to get the
bishop out to be 5 and we're gonna have
a much much different game much a much
clearer plan is going to be available
the typical Queen e1 to h4 stuff I like
the a4 move like I was saying during the
game you have play on the a file at
least if I'm gonna get in b5 I'm gonna
have to give your rook activity I grab
some space rook e1 I don't think that
this is like so bad for white oh I
actually could have grabbed this pawn I
didn't I'm not seeing that until just
now still a little crazy though still a
little crazy you have a 5 square you
have is this a file wide open your rook
on a is better than my one on B I don't
know tough game again early a suggestion
was really again pointing at that Bishop
your King Bishop get into that get them
to that be 5 square I move one two three
four right here move five Bishop b5 all
right